hi everyone in this video we'll talk
about
hybridoma technology which is a
technology for generating monoclonal
antibodies
now let us look at what are monoclonal
antibodies simply
they are antibodies which can determine
single epitope
on an antigen now what are epitopes
epitopes are antigenic determinants
so if an antibody recognize
multiple epitopes they are termed as
polyclonal antibodies
so as we understand the difference
between polyclonal and monoclonal
antibodies let us review
their usage in biomedical research so
monoclonal antibodies are
widely used in biomedical research for
several purposes such as elisa western
blotting immunofluorescence or chromatin
immunoprecipitation
other than that in terms of medicine
they are used as
therapeutics for cancer or autoimmune
diseases
so they're pretty important now in this
video let's review how they are actually
generated so first of all you need to
create
your antigen of interest against which
you want to
create a monoclonal antibody and you
would use an organism such as mouse or
rabbit as a vehicle to make these
things so the antigen of interest first
need to be
generated using recombinant dna
technology and it can be
injected in a mouse intraperitoneally so
immunizing these
mouse would generate
b cells in the spleen as it's a
blood-borne antigen
so b cells against these antigen would
be
generated in the spleen then
after some days the b cells which are
generated
against that antigen is now extracted
then they need to be cultured but there
is a fundamental problem
in terms of culturing the b cells b
cells don't survive in a culture
situation more than a week
then we can initially get some amount of
monoclonal antibodies from these b
cells but the problem is we cannot get
it for long
so what's the solution what's the
efficient solution
in order to solve this problem we use
hybridoma technology
where we use two type of cells
first one is the antigen specific b cell
extracted from the spleen of immunized
organism
now it would generate antibody but it is
not
immortal they are mortal cells now we
fuse them with the myeloma cell which
are
immortal actually they are cancer cell
lines
so while fuse them they would generate
a hybridoma cell which has
both the characteristics of these cell
types that means they can generate
antibody
as well as their immortal so the problem
is solved right
but there are nitty gritty details of
these procedure which we need to
understand
because when we are trying to add b
cells
along with the along with the myeloma
cells to generate hybridoma
there are quite a lot of cell types
which would be present in these culture
and they includes the activated the
antigen-specific
p-cell in an unfused state the myeloma
cell in an unfused state
the fused b cells and the fused myeloma
cell
and apart from all of these cell type
there would be hydro hybridoma
which is our cell type of interest so we
need only hybridoma cell types and we
need to get rid of others
now let us review that how we can do
that
so a selection procedure is required
right
and that is done by using hat media hat
media contains
hypoxanthine aminoturin and thymidine
before understanding how hat media works
and how selection procedure works we
need to understand
a very basic thing that when any cell
divide
it needs to replicate its dna right and
dna replication requires
a lot of nucleotides so nucleotide
biosynthesis is crucial for
cells to divide as well and inside a
cell
the nucleotides can be generated using
two pathways
denovo pathway and the salvage pathway
denote pathway is basically
using the or using all the ingredients
in the cell
to make nucleotides from scratch but in
this case
the amine option present in the hack
media would block
the t-novo pathway by blocking a key
enzyme in this process
known as dihydrofolate reductase
now in absence of de-novo pathway
salvage pathway is
only way of generating these nucleotides
so in salvage pathway activated ribose
base etc generates the nucleotide
so it is a way by which broken down
nucleotides can be utilized to generate
further nucleotides
and it can be done with the help of
hypoxanthine
thymidine and an enzyme known as hgprt
this particular enzyme is present in the
cells
such as b cells but absent in myeloma
cells
simply hgprt positive cells would
survive because in them salvage pathway
would occur
but hgprt minus cells would be dying
because they don't have
any ways of generating nucleotides
so they cannot divide ultimately they
would die
so let us review the all cell types that
would be generated after fusion
so there would be hybridoma cells fused
myeloma and b cells and unfused myeloma
and b
cells let us look at the hgprt negative
population myeloma cells and the fused
myeloma cells both are a gprt negative
so they would die eventually
now we are left with hybridoma cells
antigen specific b
cells and fused b cells homogeneous
fusion
how to get rid of these two cell types
so
they are not immortal
so after some time they would eventually
die
and after a few weeks we would left with
hybridoma cells only
so after getting hybridoma cells we need
to screen for
specificity of these antibodies
so these colonies of hybridoma cells
are picked up and each clones
would be cultured in a multiple plate
now from this multivolt plate the fluids
would be screened for the specificity of
antibodies
with the help of elisa or many other
ways such as western blot or
in immunofluorescence so they would be
checked for their specificity
after that if you find two or three
wells
where specific monoclonal antibodies are
generated
then these cells which are residing in
these wells
would be cultured in bulk
in a big flask and that is how we are
going to get a lot of
uh hybridoma cells which are of our
interest or which are generating
antibodies of our interest
but imagine one thing that whenever you
need a monoclonal antibody
you quickly call the biotech company and
they deliver the product in your
doorstep but
how do they produce these monoclonal
antibodies in an industry setting
and producing monoclonal antibodies in
an industrial setting needs
specialized equipment such as
bioreactors and many other procedure
procedures
i have a video on that which you can
quickly watch
by clicking on the link in the i button
so
industrial settings are very different
from a lab setting
imagine a particular monoclonal antibody
is required for your research
and you need to order it from a biotech
company and biotech company need to
produce them
in bulk in order of liters and they
would give you a tiny quantity
for your work but they are distributing
globally
so in order to know industrial setting
click on the video on the description
so i hope you enjoyed this video if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to like share and
subscribe
and guys i'm also present in an academy
which is india's biggest learning
platform if you want to learn from me
use my code ap 10 for 10 discount thank
you guys